Whatever memories of a bad break or a traumatic event may be remembered
Throughout our lives, but what if there was a way to forget all
These events? Can science allow you to erase your bad memories?
Memories are an incredibly complex process, and scientists believe it is like a fill
Closet and updated memories are stored in different parts of the brain, but now
This theory has proved to be untrue, in fact every memory is a broad process in the brain. If you've finished watching this section and do not remember it
It is because the cells in your brain have been raised and separated to build
New links will literally re-connect the circuits in your brain, and this change
Is partially facilitated by the help of proteins found in the brain.
So what happens if these proteins are not available? Simply, memories do not.
Scientists have tried this by giving animals drugs that prevent these proteins from forming
As a result, the animals were unable to remember what happened a short while later
Give her medicines
Based on this research, scientists have found a way to target long-term memories for deletion
As you see every time you remember a certain memory, your brain is separated again
And reconnect it. In fact every time you attach to the memory you literally and physically change
This anniversary in your mind, every time this little anniversary changes, to reflect
Your current thoughts, the process of remembering is a process of creation and imagination, which means that it is all
Comment on your old memories all that became more accurate.
Scientists have identified the reality of this change, after the events of September 11 a number of people
They asked about their memories of that dreadful day, and after 37% of the details were
Has changed, and by 2004 almost 50% of the details have changed or lost, because of that memories
Reconstructed and reconstituted each time. If controlled by drug inhibitor protein during
Reminds you of the memory, the anniversary will be completely deleted.
To experiment with this, scientists took laboratory mice and played a sound for them, followed by a short period
With an electric snap, after repeating this process several times the mice quickly learned that if they did
They heard the sound shortly after it would be electrocuted, and as a result the mice would freeze
Every time you hear the sound. Months later, mice will respond to sounds. whatever
If scientists have controlled the drug first, the mice will forget the memory of the sound and simply
It will go beyond that, because it will have lost the memory of the selected voice. And to make sure that the medicine
Does not cause much damage to the brain, scientists have repeated these experiments many times in many ways
Both sounds will warn of shock and both will certainly scare the mouse, but if scientists control
With the medicine and only one of the two sounds, the mouse will forget this tone only, while
He will remember his fear of the other
Over time, scientists have discovered a specific drug targeting a specific protein in
Different parts of the brain. So if you feel a terrible feeling in one of your memories, you're targeting
A specific protein in the brain's brain area will help to eliminate this link alone
Which can be an amazing tool, especially for patients with similar symptoms
Post Traumatic Stress Disorder. But while these drugs are used in very advanced stages
The question remains: If you are given a "medicine to forget" you will agree
To take it?
Special thanks to Audible.com for supporting this episode and offering a free audio book
As you choose on the audible.com/asap link. It is the leading site in the provision of audio books
With more than 150,000 titles of various literary genres. We nominate the book
"Undeniable: Evolution and the science of creation" by Bill Nye
The world who made a clip on this channel a while ago. You can download this
Audio book or other selections at audible.com/asap. And your participation
You get a free book every month! Special thanks to Audible for making this section a fact
Subscribe to more scientific sections every week!